live stream it's been a while it's been
a while we are going to talk about the
retirement of Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy I will take questions we
will do a whole bunch of stuff I don't
even know when the last time I did a
live stream was I was doing I'm pretty
frequently for a while and then I don't
know just interest kind of waned I
thought and why do it if people aren't
interested but I'm back I'm back and
we're gonna do it we're gonna do the
thing so we will I'll get to people's
questions and we're we've got plenty of
time today plenty of time to discuss and
it's actually kind of a horrible day
politically I'll talk about the
implications of Anthony Kennedy and it's
bad I try to put a positive spin on
everything when possible it's hard to
put a positive spin on the Anthony
Kennedy retirement but we'll see if
maybe we can find something not
completely disastrous about it I don't
know if this is your first live stream
and for many of you it may be because
it's been a while since I've done live
streams number one these are really live
unlike the clips that we upload these
are actually live unless you're watching
this an archived video on a replay I
will take your questions the best way
we've toyed around with different ways
to take questions during these the the
normal chat goes by really quickly so I
will remind you that you can use super
chat to send questions or to make
comments I will read them I will answer
I will react to them also any new
members and patrons who sign up during
the live streams you get a shout out
from me I'll sing your praises I will
say great things about you they may not
be true but I will I will say them
anyway and please don't troll the live
chat okay we do have moderators obvious
trolling is gonna get you banned I will
do it the moderators will do it somebody
will do it
and number five become a sponsor and we
are part of the YouTube sponsorship beta
this will also make it so that when you
type in normal chats they will look
differently so
they would look different if I type a
test you see that David Pakman show
looks different in the chat YouTube
sponsors also are identified highlighted
in the regular chat
I see Lise Hamilton already asking very
negative questions the David Pakman show
lose subscribers no we didn't we've got
four hundred and seventy five thousand
now which is more than more than ever
before and very quickly going to five
hundred thousand okay so we will get the
questions I will get to all of that
stuff sooner than later but we've got to
start by talking about what's going on
with Justice Anthony Kennedy we got the
quite frankly very bad news today that
Supreme Court Justice Anthony Kennedy is
going to be retiring and you know the
the the primary reason why this is bad
is because Donald Trump now gets to
choose a replacement and Anthony Kennedy
has been a moderate vote on the Supreme
Court Anthony Kennedy has voted in favor
of marriage equality he has been a voice
in favor of legal abortion and it is not
in any way overstating the impact of
Anthony Kennedy's retirement and
inevitable replacement with a truly
ideological hardcore right-wing
conservative justice that roe v-- wade
is now in question
gay rights could they be in question
well along the religious freedom lines
gay rights could be in question that
this is really really bad and it's
particularly upsetting to me because I
was getting messages from people on the
left during the 2016 election saying
David it doesn't matter whether it's
Trump or Hillary it makes no difference
whether it's Trump or Hillary because
they're both status quo elected official
types it doesn't make a difference one
way or the other who you vote for
and some people on the Left didn't vote
at all as a result some people on the
left
third party in states where the results
were not a guarantee and they insisted
Trump Hillary doesn't matter burn it all
down and now we have to deal with the
real consequences that by picking Neil
Gorsuch which by the way shouldn't even
have been a selection right I mean
Merrick garland should have been
confirmed this idea that in the last
year you just don't do anything if it's
under Obama you want to give people a
chance to vote it's ridiculous but they
did it and they won and now Donald Trump
gets to select a replacement for Anthony
Kennedy and this will have an impact
beyond Donald Trump's lifetime unless he
ends up living to 200 like that doctor
said he could if he just improved his
diet a little bit Hillary Clinton would
not be even considering replacing
Anthony Kennedy with somebody somebody
who might vote to overturn roe v-- wade
for somebody who might become or will
become a stalwart and steadfast right
wing voice on the Supreme Court so I'm
particularly sickened thinking back to
the Bernie ER Buster's who were
insisting that there simply is no point
in voting for Hillary or Trump that
they're both throwaway votes because
they are votes for the status quo could
not be further from the truth could not
be further from the truth and we are now
going to have to deal with that and it
is sickening and if anybody is not
sickened then you're not paying
attention because this is going to be a
win for corporations
we know that the Supreme Court
historically sides more often with
corporations than with individuals when
you have cases that involve corporate
power versus individual power that's
going to get worse we know that the
Supreme Court will often err on the side
of allowing bad things to be done to
individuals by corporations unless there
are very clear-cut cases where that
needs to be changed and that is going to
get even worse under whoever it is that
Donald Trump is select so this is a
disaster is there any silver lining is
there any way in which this is not as
bad as it could be I I don't know
I'm having trouble thinking of a way I'm
having trouble imagining how this could
possibly be worse because you are going
to have in Donald Trump a president who
is completely unqualified and lacks
knowledge even on the most basics of
economics trade geopolitics social
issues I mean really it's hard to think
of someone who knows less and he is now
going to get the opportunity to select a
second Supreme Court justice and Ruth
Bader Ginsburg would probably be the
next to retire and it may happen during
Donald Trump's first term I think that
it's possible Trump gets reelected we've
talked about that on the program
extensively very likely becomes
overwhelmingly likely that Trump would
get three or maybe even a fourth Supreme
Court pick if he is re-elected so what
we can count on is here's like
impossible sort of silver lining on this
maybe Trump's replacement of Anthony
Kennedy with a just vial right winger
will inspire people to vote them out in
November and I've been increasingly
concerned that in because of hyper
normalization initially when Trump was
elected you had interest very high from
the left the marches the activism
everything and because we're now used to
five scandals a week interest has sort
of slowly been waning and I am
extraordinarily worried that even though
Democrats have an opportunity to take
over the house in November have an
opportunity to take over the Senate in
November I am skeptical that it's going
to happen and by saying this what you
should read from it is not well let's
forget about November it's I've got to
make sure to vote I've got to make sure
to get people registered to vote that is
the one and only path forward and I just
can't even imagine it's hard to even
understand the magnitude particularly if
Donald Trump chooses someone who's
younger someone in their early 50s even
potentially somebody in their 40s to
replace
Anthony Kennedy you are talking about an
impact on our country that will last
potentially a generation or longer and I
people know that I am NOT one of these
I'm gonna move to Canada types first of
all I understand that it's really
difficult to move to Canada as much as
we might sometimes like to I have never
participated in the if exile moved to
Canada if Bush is reelected I'll move to
Canada or any of that stuff I've just
not done it but I would be lying if I
didn't tell you that over the last
several weeks I have started to have
real sort of thoughts about not I'm
gonna in protest move right I'm it
wouldn't be a protest thing but I start
thinking about we've got the sort of
suggestion from Trump of skipping the
Constitution when it comes to
undocumented immigrants we've got this
decidedly authoritarian move you've got
a guy who is deliberately seemingly
deliberately or at least recklessly
ruining relationships with longtime
American allies I have started to think
about well what would it be like if for
some period of time I moved somewhere
else my options basically are Argentina
and Israel right though those are my two
options I think I've told the story
before of how my family because my
family left Poland shortly before World
War two we would hypothetically be able
to get polish passports which confer EU
privileges but because the birth
certificate of my polish grandfather was
misplaced during World War two that's a
difficult thing it's actually a
conversation I'm having with people I'm
having a cut the conversation with
people in my life I'm having the
conversation with with friends and
family because that's actually how bad
it is getting and I know that there are
people in the audience also who are not
in the let's move to Canada thing who
are just genuinely horrified by what it
is that's going on and the Supreme Court
thing is going to be an absolute and
total disaster there is no other way
around it and I hate to break it to you
because since day one of
Trump administration I have been sort of
optimistic that now that people get it
now that people understand the magnitude
of these elections that support of
independent media has escalated and that
was true for a while after Trump's
election shows like mine and others that
are similar to mine that have presences
on YouTube and other social media we've
seen an increase in financial
contributors we've seen an increase in
traffic it's all just been going way way
up D monetization hit on YouTube
we had another massive wave massive
massive wave of supporters that came in
the rallies the activism it was
abundantly clear why this was a time to
be active and in April last month in May
our support has started to wane a little
bit a lot of those people that signed up
four year memberships in April and May
of 2017 have been choosing not to renew
them in May of 2018
I've spoken to other hosts that I'm sure
you know but because they didn't say you
can mention my name I'm not going to
mention their names other hosts are
seeing the same thing some of the
support that we gained early in the
Trump presidency has started to fade and
I believe that there is a hyper
normalization that's going on people get
accustomed to the fact that there are
scandals every day essentially every
week if not every day people are getting
accustomed to the authoritarian slide
and this is how authoritative really
takes hold which is not from one day to
the next with media attacks it's the
development of the term fake news
singling out individual media outlets
talking about requiring journalism
licenses whatever that would even mean
starting to talk about other ways to
suppress critical voices in media and
over time people become desensitized to
this concerted attack on a free press
which is one of the institutions of the
United States of America that actually
serves as a check and balance when it
works appropriately not when it's
co-opted by corporate interests against
government power
people are forgetting and I talked about
it earlier on in the program we've seen
our patreon numbers I'm sure you've
noticed trickling down we have seen what
was initially a big upswing and the
number of YouTube sponsors the level out
and start to trickle other shows are
experiencing it and we're gonna do
everything we can to be bigger than ever
but I am concerned about because what I
went when you don't see progressive
independent media supported that makes
me think that interest in voting in
November is also not going to be there
that makes me think that activating
against the Trump administration is
going to start waning so I'm concerned I
am I'm significantly concerned about
what is going on and I'm obviously I
hope that I'm wrong right I hope that
that this is some kind of temporary
thing I hope that it is just a brief
problem that shows like ours are
experiencing but everybody's saying the
exact same thing and that is
extraordinarily concerning to me let me
get to some of the super chats and
different things that are going on as a
reminder if this this is my first live
stream in a while if this is your first
live stream there really live unless
you're watching a replay if you have
questions for me I try to follow the the
chat but it is hard because it moves
pretty quickly
use super chat to send comments and ask
questions and I will get to them I will
get to them if you are so kind as to
sign up for a membership or make a
pledge on patreon while we are doing the
stream then I will give you a shout out
and sing your praises and that will be a
really good thing and please don't troll
the chat I'm saying that there is some
trolling going on there's a couple
people who have already been banned and
that that's just don't do it it's not
funny and it's not fun and it's sad that
people waste their time trolling and
lastly we are now part of the YouTube
sponsorship beta so that is something
else that you can do if you want to
support our work ok Steve Braun sent a
$5 super chat as you can see up there
asking what do you think about Acacio
being a democratic social the essay and
that the DSA identifies as
anti-capitalist well listen I am for
social democracy right I've been very
clear that I am NOT a socialist I
have no problem debunking failed talking
points about socialism but I've been
very clear that what I think is the best
system is one that allows for the
rewards of innovation and
entrepreneurship because I believe
incredibly strongly that
entrepreneurship is a driving force of
innovation in Western democracies but I
believe that in exchange for that system
and the ability to do entrepreneurship
and build successful businesses we need
to it is a moral imperative and it is an
economic imperative to have very
well-funded social safety nets so that's
where I come down I am I am in favor of
social democracy means you can build a
really big business and you can be very
successful if that's your thing but at
the same time if it's not regardless of
what job you choose to have regardless
even if you choose not to have a job we
should be providing health care we
should be ensuring that education is
strong so on and so forth okay so that
that's my view and I think it people by
and large know that that I am NOT a
socialist I don't really I'm not
concerned in any way that Alexandria
Ocasio courts has identifies as part of
DSA as a democratic socialist the truth
is that the United States is not at it
even remote risk of becoming a socialist
nation and to the extent that a
Democratic Socialist can lobby for
stronger social welfare programs and a
safety net I think it's absolutely
fantastic there is too much lack of
diversity Democrats and Republicans
exist within a pretty narrow scope in
the House and Senate yes you've got
Republicans increasingly extreme but you
have very few true progressive leftists
that our elected officials and I though
I'm not a democratic socialist myself I
am NOT concerned whatsoever I think it's
a great thing and I look forward to
seeing what if indeed she wins the
general election would Alexandria Acacio
Cortes does now my caveat is and I'm not
afraid to say this and she's welcome on
the program any time and we can talk
policy I have not been hugely impressed
by her ability to go deep on policy okay
so I know
that she has run on a number of
different she has a number of different
positions medicare-for-all abolishing
ice right so I've seen the list of
positions I've not been dramatically
impressed with her ability to go into
depth about lots of those issues and I
welcome the opportunity to be proven
wrong and she's welcome on my program
absolutely any time okay another super
chap that came in from Ninh Jack's ex
David give me your straight opinion how
bad is Justice Kennedy's announcement
what would that I opened the livestream
with that it's really bad
it's really bad and I can't think of how
to sugarcoat it but it is
extraordinarily bad the timing could not
be worse Donald Trump could end up with
three or maybe even four picks for the
Supreme Court by the time that it's all
said and done and it is absolutely
atrocious this is a guy who has been the
quote moderate vote and he has voted the
right way a number of times he voted the
right way on banning state-level bans on
same-sex marriage he has been a defender
of at least some access to abortion
services for women and what you will
basically see once Kennedy is replaced
with a lunatic religious right ideologue
what you're going to see is John Roberts
become the swing vote and that is the
stuff of nightmares I mean absolutely
totally stuff of nightmares another
super chat from sinister minister who
says the next American Civil War begins
with Trump yeah I saw a poll today which
said something along the lines of some
crazy percentage of the country
predicted civil war or even wanted it I
don't I don't remember exactly I
bookmarked it to look at for tomorrow it
was I'm not I'm not going to predict
Civil War but the country you know we
always hear the country is as divided as
ever this feels like a slightly
different type of division I'm not
saying it's the worst it's ever been or
it's not as bad as it's ever been what
I'm saying is there's a different tone
tenner to the division that we're seeing
right now I hope that there is no such
Civil War but I think that the division
is of a different type than what we've
seen for a while rich Parata sent a $5
super chat thank you rich saying if
Democrats take over the House Senate and
presidency what's the chance of
establishing term limits for the House
Senate and Supreme Court almost nothing
rich almost nothing I've talked about
how I would actually be in favor of term
limits for the House Senate and the
Supreme Court there are different
reasons why I think it makes sense for
the House and Senate and why it makes
sense for the Supreme Court the overlap
being that lifetime appointments and the
ability to be re-elected and definitely
do impact the accountability that people
have and I know that you often hear well
we don't want if you can if judges are
elected then they make decisions for
political reasons to get reelected
that's true but if there's simply as
limit as to how long you can be on the
Supreme Court
you actually have freedom to make the
decisions you think are right because
either way you're out and I think that
that would be a really good thing but
unfortunately rich it's not gonna happen
because as I've said before you know one
of the most disgusting talking points
and misinformation that we saw around
the 2016 election was Hillary and Trump
are the same Hillary and Trump doesn't
make a difference who you vote for we're
seeing a difference right now okay
Donald Trump got himself bamboozled by
Kim jong-un Hillary Clinton wouldn't
have Donald Trump is going to appoint a
disgusting a second disgusting religious
right ideologue to the Supreme Court who
potentially would even vote to overturn
roe v wade Hillary Clinton would not
have done that so the idea that there is
no difference there is
multi-generational impact based on the
difference between Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump and it is called the
Supreme Court and I know that there are
people out there who like to say doesn't
matter ultimately the Supreme Court is
truly controlled by who is in the Senate
because we saw Merrick garland
obstructed by Mitch McConnell and that's
actually what matters well yeah that
makes a difference but ultimately if
you're not selected by the president you
don't become a Supreme Court justice and
whoever is going to be suggested by
Trump as the replacement to Hillary
Clinton to Anthony Kennedy is not
someone who would have even had a shot
if we had president Hillary Clinton I
major problems with Hillary I voted for
Bernie Sanders in the primary right I'm
not hiding any of the problems with
Hillary but anybody who is insisting
that they are the same or would have
been the same I you could not be more
wrong you could not be more wrong Justin
Rosato sent a $2 99 cent super chat
asking is there any chance that Congress
can reject this I assume you mean reject
the ability for Donald Trump to replace
Anthony Kennedy I believe that if
Democrats can filibuster they should and
they should say we should at least wait
until the midterms before we do any
hearings because Trump Republicans
rather said when Obama nominated Merrick
garland
we've only got a year left in the
presidency let's let people vote before
we do any changes to the Supreme Court I
think Democrats would be completely
accurate in saying well we've only got
four months at this point four months in
a few days until the midterm elections
we're not doing anything until then and
then if they do take over the House and
Senate then do everything they can to
block the nomination will they do it
probably not probably not I don't think
that they're going to do it
night Builders is a new sponsor on
YouTube
Thank You night builders and please make
a comment in the chat because now all
YouTube sponsors in the chat are
designated in a particular way I don't
know exactly what it is I think it's our
icon that we have uploaded so please say
hello in the chat night builders and
thanks thanks for becoming a sponsor we
have another super chat from Izzy
Sanchez Jr who has sent a five-dollar
super chat asks with the ballooning debt
under Trump can be used to push for a
blue wave this November no and the
reason why is as follows the
1 the debt is a political football and
we've discussed modern monetary theory
and the the actual amount of debt is not
actually that politically relevant and
it's not that economically relevant but
it is a political football typically it
is Democrats who believe in increases to
the debt being justifiable increases to
the deficit rather being justifiable if
the money is being used in an
economically stimulative way and
normally it's the Republicans who say
under no circumstances do we increase
the deficit under no circumstances do we
focus on anything economically other
than paying off the national debt and of
course they're hypocrites because george
w bush blew up the deficit and donald
trump is blowing it up but i do not
believe that that is a winning issue for
Democrats particularly because I don't
think it's a good political issue at all
most people don't actually understand
debt and deficit and given what we're
learning based on modern monetary theory
I just don't think it's the hill to die
on for Democrats so no unfortunately is
he I don't think that that is going to
be a winning strategy for a blue wave I
think the winning strategy for the blue
wave is here are the policy issues that
will be the priority of Democrats from
2018 to 2020 impeachment I don't think
should be one of them and I've explained
why I'm not saying Trump shouldn't be
impeached I'm just saying I wouldn't run
on impeachment if I were Democrats and
we'll dig into that a little more in the
next couple weeks David Moss sent the $2
super chat thoughts on Dave Rubens last
interview with Joe Rogan I only saw a
little bit and what I saw was really bad
okay it's like I think it was a three
hour interview I just don't have time to
watch a three hour interview
unfortunately I'm not bragging about
being busy I think that's not something
to brag about but I just don't have time
to watch a three hour interview the
portion that people sent me was when
Dave rube but there were two portions
that were just really not good and I'd
love to talk to Dave Rubin about this
anytime he's welcome on the show anytime
and it's not I don't think he's a bad
person for making these arguments I just
think
wrong he was arguing against government
regulation on the basis using
homebuilders as an example which is just
a disastrous example because actually
not enough regulation on homebuilders
has led to absolute disasters for
homeowners so it was a just
embarrassingly bad example and the
number two it was a port a section about
the government not being good at doing
things and he used some example about
UPS USPS and shipping live baby chickens
and it was just a total implosion I mean
just absolute total implosion and he was
all sweaty during it and I don't know if
he was sweaty because it he was getting
nervous at how bad the implosion was or
maybe joe rogan keeps his studio really
hot but it was it was not good it was
not not a good not a good thing and that
that's all I saw of it and it's possible
that there were other parts that were
really really good but I didn't see them
I didn't see them I want to say thanks
to Jordan Barnard who just increased
their patreon contribution from $1 a
month to $2 a month I also want to say
thanks to Timothy Carr Timothy Carr just
pledged $2 a month on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show let
me mention this is actually a good
opportunity to mention we have something
pretty interesting going on with patreon
what we're doing with patreon in order
to so I've mentioned that it has gotten
bad on patreon we've actually a lot of
shows like ours have lost quite a bit of
support on patreon and a lot of this I
think has to do with sort of political
fatigue as well as hyper normalization
of daily scandals so what we're doing is
when we get to 2,000 patrons I am going
to be playing a live game of chess
against producer Pat and producer max
I'm not very good at chess but I do
enjoy playing it so the idea is once we
get to 2,000 patrons were at about 1800
73 actually 1875 right now we're gonna
do that livestream and I will actually
make an offer to you tonight if we get
to 1,900 patrons before the end of the
stream so that's just 25 more patrons I
will actually play a game or two of
chess
for you on the stream tonight just to
show you my skill level at the risk of
significantly embarrassing myself I will
play a game or two of chess on LY chess
org so let's play by all means help us
let's get those contributions in I would
love to play a game of chess or two or
two and embarrass myself this evening
and also I want to mention that the
other way that you can get a big thank
you during the stream is if you sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership
that is the number one funding source
for the show if you've never heard of it
we really do depend on that funding you
can also use a coupon code vote soon 18
it'll save you 40% you save 40% you get
100% of the benefits and I will also
shout you out during the live stream so
a couple ways to be mentioned all of
them support the work that we do and
offer stands if we get to 2,000 patrons
tonight I'll pull up and play a couple
games of chess and significantly
embarrass myself $5.00 super chat from
PDX pro career tips and tricks David if
you were religious would you think Trump
is the Antichrist or realistic
equivalent I don't even know how to
answer that because it's just that
that's not my worldview that's not how I
see the world it's not how I think about
things so I mean I religious or not my
humanist values enable me to see that
Trump is an abomination period right and
I don't I don't know that any kind of
religious interpretation or worldview
would necessarily change that but I'm
not religious so I guess I'm probably
not the right person to answer that let
me take a look through the regular chat
don't want to ignore people let's see if
there's any questions there that might
be important for me to answer a couple
people saying David White why do you
hate the green part
I don't hate the Green Party I think
Jill Stein is not a good candidate I
don't think that she would make a good
president period
I think the Green Party has had too many
dances with just genuinely really bad
ideas at one point having federal
funding for homeopathy on on their
platform
I think the Green Party has I can I be
charitable and say they probably have
good intentions but I don't see the
future of progressivism in the Green
Party don't hate it don't hate Green
Party voters I just don't don't see the
future of progressivism there let's see
what else is going on in the regular
chat David you should go on the Joe
Rogan program I would go on any time I
actually did make contact with Joe's
producer at one point and was basically
given like a will let you know type of
thing and I haven't heard from them
since but I would be willing to be on
absolutely any time what else do we have
a lot of comments not seeing a lot of
specific questions there but I'll go
back and check it out homeopathy is
insane race IQ is just racism Trump is a
fascist
I don't think Trump is a fascist Trump
is more of a corporate status Trump
would like to be sort of an
authoritarian fascist but I think Trump
is more of a corporate status 12 an in
normal capitalism bedfellows bed
fellowship of government and
corporations that that that's what I see
more than anything else okay let's see
what else we've got here Steve Braun
what's the difference between Germany
and teabag the tea bag isn't bitter when
it's taken out of the cup how excited
were you about Argentina today so if you
don't know I'm from Argentina I'm not an
American but I'm not Mexican
today's hatred mail misinterpreted me
being Argentinian as me as me being
Mexican which which I'm not I'm
Argentinian is a different country I
thought it was over for Argentina
Argentina tied their
game in the World Cup against Iceland
not a good start if you're supposed to
be one of the top four teams in the
World Cup then lost I believe it was 3-0
in the end to Croatia absolutely
disastrous and then was able to pull out
a win against Nigeria and now will face
France in the first round of the
tournament style the single elimination
portion of the World Cup
I was hugely hugely excited and to be
honest I have no problem with the German
people or with the country of Germany
Germany always gets out of trouble with
some last minute goal and I was glad to
see Germany eliminated from the World
Cup today first time since 1938 think
about what was going on in Germany in
1938 that Germany doesn't advance beyond
group play so yeah Saturday 10:00 a.m.
Eastern Time I will be very very
excitedly watching the World Cup a
couple new thank-yous I want to do I
want to thank also patreon a lot of new
patreon patrons all of a sudden on
patreon Ripa me Leela me Leela I'm
butchering your name I apologize has
made a pledge of $1 a month
Thank You Hayden Ellison has made a
pledge of $1 a month on patreon Andrew
Jones has made a pledge of $2 a month on
patreon and Ripa says greetings from
Finland I am going to Finland in
September okay I am so excited about
this Ripa I am going to be going to
Helsinki in September it's going to be
part of when we do David Pakman show
sort of summer vacation although it'll
be closer to fall I am going to be in
Helsinki I will be over in Tallinn
Estonia and I'm just so excited I've
heard great things about Finland if you
have recommendations about what is worth
doing in Helsinki not gonna have time to
get out of the city but I do look
forward to checking out checking out
Helsinki so as I mentioned if we get to
1900 patrons during the street
I will play a couple games of chess live
for you you will see me more than likely
get embarrassed because I'm not good but
we can consider it sort of training for
when we get to 2,000 patrons and we do
our live david pakman show chess
tournament where i will play on a
livestream a game of chess against
producer pat and producer max playing
jointly because as bad as i am they play
even less than I do so that's the idea
let's get to the the 1900 and then I'll
do it okay a few more Super chats here
ace a Tanaka sent a $10 superjet hey
Dave as an ex Muni meaning the
unification Church I just wanted to know
your thoughts on the movement also I
appreciate you and other progressives
for helping me change my beliefs to
secularism yeah I don't know that much
about the Moonies and the unification
Church I know that it is a cult-like
if not a cult I think it's okay to say
to say it's a cult but but maybe not so
I'll say cult-like
I know that they had a bizarre ceremony
recently where they had some kind of
commitment ceremony to their ar-15 style
rifles and it's not an organization that
I would want anything to do with and I'm
glad that you found your way out of it
ace a very very good ricky soul was sent
to $5 super chat saying LOL at that
water slurp did it was it audible it was
horrible
it was audible I apologize for that
Matthew Griffin $5 super chat would you
be interested in debating race or eye
race versus IQ on your show I hate the
cause correlation argument with love to
see you debate more in general you know
I'm not an expert on race in IQ right we
did a heavily researched piece on race
and IQ and I came to the audience with
that and I've interviewed people about
race and IQ but really it's experts on
race and IQ that should be debating it
so I don't know that I'm actually the
right person for it Joe Rader has sent a
five-dollar super chat Thank You David
your live stream came on just as I was
preparing my home chef meal great talk
great eats thanks alright well very good
sound sounds delicious
Brandon Roach sent a $5 super chat with
Justice Anthony
any retiring do you feel there is any
risk there is a risk of any current
progress with LGBTQ rights being
reversed yeah I do I think that we are
at risk of roe v-- wade being overturned
once Donald Trump replaces Anthony
Kennedy with a total and vile ideologue
I think that LGBTQ right progress also
is at risk I think that corporate power
is going to be escalated even further by
whoever it is that Donald Trump chooses
to replace Anthony Kennedy with and it's
bad it's gonna be really really bad
Jonathan Loomis sends a five-dollar
super chat saying Mitch McConnell is a
world-class hypocrite Twitter should not
be allowed any judicial nominees while
he is under investigation for
obstruction ah you know there's actually
that that I think that's a tough one to
make because ultimately it's not it is
Meccano McConnell's responsibility to
decide on confirmation hearings but
ultimately it's really the president who
decides who is going to be nominated to
the Supreme Court I think that if you
want to make that case you make the case
that while the president's entire
administration is under investigation
for possibly really serious crimes
related to the 2016 election that would
be a reason for a moratorium on Supreme
Court picks but I say it as a thought
experiment I mean it's totally academic
at this point because it's just not
gonna happen
I do want to say thank you to a new
David Pakman show member membership is
such a great thing we have been
disproportionately supported by
membership for years on the program and
every time we get a new member I get an
email and it is just the most inspiring
moment of the day when we get new
members Guillaume Roe Schwartz has
become a david pakman show member
guillaume has used the coupon code vote
soon a teen meaning guillaume has saved
40% off of his membership the
reason why why would you want to become
a member the reason you would want to
become a member is that membership
confers a number of great benefits
including the daily bonus show including
daily one-hour commercial free david
pakman show episodes instead of waiting
for those five to seven-minute YouTube
clips to be released each day and you're
supporting our work you're supporting
independent media you're supporting the
expansion of the show you're supporting
the fact that we have recently cut down
the amount of commercials during every
hour of the David Pakman show so though
those are pretty damn good reasons to me
to become a david pakman show member and
anybody else who signs up during the
stream I will give a shout-out to and
thank a couple other things that we have
coming up on the program the
pseudoscience miniseries is going to
start being released at the end of next
week
if you've not heard about the
pseudoscience miniseries we're
publishing a teaser episode later this
week members already got access to that
teaser episode and the pseudoscience
miniseries will be a 12 part breakdown
of 12 different pseudo-sciences they
will include homeopathy they will
include psychics they will include
astrology and I actually am kind of
worried a little bit about the impact
that this miniseries is going to have
because the preview episode that we
released is the one on ESP extrasensory
perception and I actually heard from
some angry angry people saying David
it's real ESP is real and psychics are
real so I I do think that this
unfortunately is going to be a
miniseries that is well received by many
will almost knock my water over but also
is going to anger a bunch of people and
you know what I have never shied away
from doing content the way I want to do
it because it might upset somebody we
don't allow ourselves to be taken
hostage
for financial support and we're gonna do
every story the way we want to do that
Nicholas Shaw sent a $2 super chat Thank
You Parker sent a $2 super chat Ches
what a nerd loved the show David yeah so
I mentioned that I have been playing
some chess and apparently there are tons
of chess players in the audience and as
a result we said when we get to 2,000
patrons we will do some chess matches
and one the first one will be a
livestream where I will play against
producer Pat and producer max I also
said that if we get to 1,900 patrons
tonight during the livestream I will
play a game or two of chess and for your
I guess viewing pleasure we are at 1879
patrons we started the evening at 1873
or 1879 if we get 21 more patrons I will
play a game or two of chess for you but
it's gonna have to happen kind of
quickly it's gonna have to happen kind
of quickly I do want to thank Brandon
Roach who just became a patron but we do
not have unlimited time actually the
reason is that I have to work on
tomorrow's show David Moss says is there
a policy where you are right-wing on I
can't think of one I can't think of a
policy where I'm I am right wing right
wing being defined of course as either
conservative or reactionary I guess or
against progress for the sake of being
against progress I don't know no I can't
think of any David I want to thank sandy
Klaussner sandy Klaussner has become a
youtube sponsor gr has made an
appearance $2 super chat saying PAC DZ I
love you long time no Haeckel love gr gr
is a really great guy and gr did
something a little while ago where he
donated a whole bunch of memberships to
david pakman show viewers who couldn't
afford them and it was a really great
thing and a few people in David Pakman
show history have done it few have done
more for the David Pakman show than gr
who always shows up with the Super chats
shows up with donated member
chips and and all sorts of great ways to
support the work that we are doing so
great to see you gr glad you're here and
also thanks to Shane babka Shane babka
is a new YouTube sponsor and as many of
you know babka basically my favorite
dessert pistachio baklava and babka are
III I would say my two favorite non
Argentinian desserts Argentinian
desserts I think well that's a story for
another day maybe maybe if we got a
sponsor maybe if we got a super chat
asking about my favorite Argentinian
resorts I would mention that but Shane
congratulations for having the last name
of truly one of the great desserts
in world history I would venture to say
I don't think that that's hyperbolic in
any way I also want to send a quick
thank you to stout and ingest out ninja
just made a $2.00 a month pledge on
patreon putting us at one thousand eight
hundred and eighty if we get twenty more
we started the evening at eighteen
seventy three we picked up seven patrons
during the livestream and we are now at
eighteen eighty if we get to 1,900 by
the end of the livestream I will play I
guess at this point because it's
dragging on a little I'll play one live
game of chess I may get crushed and it
may be hugely embarrassing but I will do
it for you
Jonathan Campbell has sent a four dollar
and ninety nine cent super chap saying
I'm extremely worried about the midterms
Democrats better not dismiss voting
because of the Blue Wave talk thinking
there will be a major turnout I am
extraordinarily concerned about the 2018
midterms I think that for the same
reason that progressive media has been
seeing a little bit of a trailing off
financial support I've experienced it a
bunch of other shows have experienced it
I think that it is tied to decreased
urgency about voting turnout in midterms
is pathetically low and I want to take a
moment here to address a talking point
that is disgustingly destructive when it
comes to voting how many of you have
heard
the talking point that elections rarely
depend on one vote so therefore my vote
makes no difference so therefore I'm
gonna stay home okay I think most of us
have heard that talking point that
talking point is the epitome of
logically fallacious and I'm going to
explain it to you it's true right rarely
does a Senate election a congressional
election presidential election rarely
does it come down to one vote but the
truth is that a lot of people have that
thought they say because my vote
wouldn't by itself swing the election I
might not vote if everybody who thought
that didn't vote collectively those
votes would actually have the chance of
losing or winning an election so
whenever anybody says to you
elections are never decided by a vote
they are decided by more so my vote
doesn't matter you say if everybody who
thought that stayed home that group of
people of which you would be a part
would lose an election that we could
have otherwise won so do not under any
circumstances let people get away with
that a completely bogus talking point
Albert soleus sent a five-dollar super
chat saying hey David how much do you
follow argentinian politics are you
still keeping up with the story of the
murder of argentinian lawyer Alberto
nisman I have not kept up with the nice
Minh story as much over the last few
months I do follow Argentinean politics
I watch news from Argentina on a
basically daily basis most mornings when
I'm preparing the show I'm actually
watching live streams of Argentinian
news rather than that American news but
you know the situation in Argentina if
you think that there's toxic
partisanship and divisions in the US you
should see it in my within my family in
Argentina there is a rule that politics
simply can't be discussed at anything
family gathering you just just you can't
discuss politics because it's too it's
it's too toxic and it just doesn't it
everybody has a bad time when politics
are discussed so it's it's really bad
let me say thank you to another patron I
want to say thanks to Joshua and Maconie
or Makani I'm not sure exactly how it's
pronounced but I know that the first
name is Joshua and Joshua has made a
pledge of $2 a month
Thank You Joshua thank you talk to
Joshua I really appreciate it we have
suffered a decrease in our patreon
platform and we are doing everything we
can to rebuild it if we get to 1,900
patrons by the end of the night I will
play a quick game of chess just as a
preview for the eventual eventual big
battle that we will be having at the
David Pakman show also want to say
thanks to a new member it's not just
patrons who get shoutouts it's new
YouTube sponsors and super chatters and
new members I want to say a major thank
you to Jay captain Jake Upton has
recently signed up just in the last few
minutes at david pakman.com slash
membership and of course all supporters
are hugely hugely appreciated including
high vibes sound system who has sent a
dollar super chat okay let me talk to
you about something I want to get your
advice about this should we do a
long-form piece about Jordan Peterson
okay and the reason I ask is the
following there is a lot of nonsense to
debunk about Jordan Peterson but at the
same time there are people in our
audience who don't like hearing about
Jordan Peterson either because they
don't care or because they believe that
I have a personal obsession with Jordan
Peterson and am jealous of him in some
way I'm not going to become defensive I
would just ask you to give me reason to
believe that I am in some way jealous or
bitter about Jordan Peterson I think
that the guy is
full of a lot of really bad ideas and I
think that well I've talked about the
intellectual dark web but we get a lot
of requests for a long forum about
Jordan Peterson and I got a lot of
requests never to talk about Jordan
Peterson so I don't know maybe this
would be something for a I don't even
know how to do it make a pledge on
patreon of a dollar and one cent if you
yes want the Jordan Peterson thing and
pledge a dollar in two cents if you
don't want the Jordan Peterson thing I
don't know I don't even know if you can
do pennies on on patreon sory deokman
Yehia has sent a five dollar super chat
saying how far will argentina go in the
world cup I'm going to be optimistic and
say that Argentina will go all the way
and we'll come away victorious in the
World Cup do I actually believe that the
odds are on their side maybe not but
I've got to support my team and I think
that Argentina it's one game at a time
it's France Saturday at 10:00 a.m.
Eastern Time that's all that has to
happen then we'll see about the future
future of the World Cup Nicholas Shaw is
asking me whether I would support a Joe
Kennedy 2020 run depends who else is
running I think right now 2020 is a
distraction I think that the important
thing is to focus on November of 2018
that that's it and I've been saying for
a while that I think it's too early it's
premature to talk about 2020 I like Joe
Kennedy I would be open to supporting
Joe Kennedy depending on who else runs
because there's people that I like more
than Joe Kennedy and there's certainly
people that Joe Kennedy would be my
choice over know no doubt about it but
Joe Kennedy a very interesting
politician and he I don't know the
Kennedy you know there's this whole cult
of personality around the Kennedys I've
never been hugely drawn into it I know
that there are there are lots of people
in our audience who are very very into
the entire sort of Kennedy what would
you call a milieu or I don't know what
what word to use for it I've never been
like a big Kennedy
Kennedy file but I actually find Joe
Kennedy to be a sort of different type
of politician than some of the other
Kennedys and I would be I would be
interested in seeing his political
career develop but he's not the most
progressive guy so whether I would
support him for president depends on
what what the alternatives are and and I
would prefer a real progressive I just
don't think that the guys is progressive
in the same sense that that a lot of
other people are a couple comments in
the chat about what's going on with
fourth of July are we going to be off
for the 4th of July we are going to be
off for the 4th of July as you know I
think it is very important right right
now in particular and in general that
staff get time off and that people do
things other than just working all the
time so we are going to be taking a
couple days off for the 4th of July and
we have content new content will still
be released to the YouTube channel but
there will not be new shows filmed so
you know hopefully the puppet masters of
world news will not break any news
during our break because otherwise we
will be I don't know we'll fall behind
then it wouldn't be good al Castle 84
has sent a $4 and $0.99 super chat says
it's the post American world here yeah I
know at the beginning of the stream al I
was talking about how I have never even
joked about if Bush is reelected I'll
move to Canada if this or that happens
I'll move here move there but there is
something tangibly different that I have
been experiencing during the last
particularly the last three months the
authoritarian slides the attacks on
press freedom the casual suggestion to
just ignore the Constitution and deport
certain people detained at the border
with with absolutely no due process now
the ability for Donald Trump the
opportunity for Donald Trump to appoint
another Supreme Court justice I have
actually started thinking should I look
at maybe
spending most of the next few years in
Argentina where I could because I was
born there should I look at spending the
rest of the next few years in Israel
which is really the only other place I
could go from from a legal perspective
because it's it's not about hyperbole
and it's not about making a political
statement it's just it's getting really
bad and I know that being in
Massachusetts I'm somewhat insulated
from it because we have we are in
Massachusetts one of the most
progressive states in the country but it
is really becoming concerning in a way
that I that I think is very different
than much of what we saw up certainly
under george w bush and i'm by no means
romanticizing the bush administration
want to say thanks to another new member
Jay McCarroll Aine has become a member
at david pakman.com slash membership Jay
thank you thank you sincerely thank you
for becoming a member I really really
appreciate it you can also save 40% off
of your membership if you use the coupon
code vote soon 18 Izzy Sanchez jr. is
asking with the amount of humanitarian
crises created under this administration
how many administrations would it take
to fix the mess Trump has made yeah so
early in the Trump administration I made
the point that Donald Trump is signing a
lot of horrible executive orders he is
ruining our reputation around the world
but he hadn't at that time actually done
that much destructive stuff that has
changed right now the tariffs I don't
have to give you the full list there
have actually been completely
destructive policies and decisions made
by Donald Trump and the climate
decisions particularly could take many
presidencies many presidencies to undo
and some of them simply cannot be undone
right it's just the time we lose on
climate is not time we're ever going to
get back with the ability now to choose
Anthony Kennedy's replacement Donald
Trump could do multi-generational damage
or at least transgenerational damage
right look beyond the current
generation to the next one so it could
take many administration's every month
that Donald Trump is in the White House
that is more time that the administered
ministrations will have to devote to
trying to undo the damage he's done
Cerreta Achmed Yehia has sent another
super chat thank you I suggest you read
eben Khaldoun calden about the rise and
fall of Empire if I find an argument in
that for the super spending we do on
military that's interesting I've heard
that book mentioned I don't know much
about it but I will I will check it out
it sounds like it could be interesting
although I've gotten really really picky
about what books I read because I read
this interesting piece not that long ago
about how you can only read a limited
number of books in your life and I think
we all sort of know that intuitively but
the article really made the case that if
you start a book and you get fifty pages
in and it's not doing it for you there's
no shame in leaving it that you should
be really sort of thoughtful in terms of
which books you select because it's a
commitment and you you've only got time
for a certain number of books so I have
definitely become pickier than ever when
it comes to what what books what books I
read okay I think that there are some
people who have made stream Labs
contributions even though we've sort of
moved again from stream labs so let me
just check that out because I don't want
to miss miss anybody if they have made
contributions just one okay so Yesenia
Yesenia says Joe Kennedy just endorsed
progressive Ammar compa do you think Ben
Jealous
and Alexandria Cortez's win influenced
his endorsement maybe I'm not sure about
that I don't know that much about about
the dynamics of sort of Joe Kennedy's
political posturing so I'm not sure
Yesenia
Brandon Roach has sent a dollar super
chat and I very very much appreciate
that as well thanks to everybody who
joined me that is it for this live
stream if people get in touch and say
they like the live stream
if I get comments through patreon or
membership that people are signing up
because the live stream I am ready
willing and able to go back to regular
live streams as I said at the beginning
I kind of stopped because interest
seemed to be waning but if the interest
is back I will be back and before I go
ng bengi mm sent the superjet saying you
ever get a treat from my cousin's food
truck the Cookie Monster best cookie
you'll find in Boston I have not heard
of it I have not visited it but I will
look it up in ghee bengi sounds
interesting
all right I'll see everybody soon